is a beast okay that's true and he's a
beast he's a beast and he keeps popping
Donald Trump in all of his folks in the
mouth Jon Meacham says he may be the
savior of the Republic he really is a
master of the media cycle I owe Michael
avenatti an apology for the last couple
of weeks I've been saying I'm not for
reading Michael I've seen you everywhere
what do you have left to say I was wrong
brother you have a lot to say the
Democrats could learn something for you
savior of the Republic who gives these
people TV shows for months as you know
the press could not get enough of the
world's creepiest porn lawyer hundreds
of fawning media appearances propelled
him to become a leading Democratic
candidate for the presidency which is
where he is right now but in the last
two weeks an entirely by accident the
creepy porn lawyer reminded the public
about why evidence and the presumption
of innocence still matter in the country
and may have saved Brett Kavanaugh in
the process so now these four
benefactors are mad and they're turning
on him some of your Democratic
colleagues have been saying that the
Democrats your fellow Democrats case
against justice Cavanaugh was weakened
by a Michael avenatti Michael is
probably the best thing to happen to red
Cavanaugh I mean all these Democrats
that have been flirting with him they've
got to really be embarrassed a lot of
Democrats are saying and are you hearing
this
that avenatti took what was a
sympathetic case with Ford and turned it
into a circus losing them the high
ground yeah I'm here the Michael
avenatti circus comes to town avenatti
came in with the sweat neck allegations
of drug gang rape stuff that seems to
have been much less taken as credible
Aven and he did a huge favor to the
front White House they're concerned that
he might be hurting their beloved
political party David Brown is an
attorney's director of the Brunswick
group he's a former advisor to Senator
patty Murray nee joins us I'm David
thank you a lot for coming on so does it
turn out that stormy Daniels his former
lawyer is not in the end the savior of
the Republic as MSNBC dubbed him I think
it gives it gives Michael avenatti a
little too much credit to say that he
really was the deciding factor in this I
think we we know that that now justice
Cavanaugh was confirmed because of a
process that the Republicans ran and
they were single-minded and determined
and insuring
nomination no matter the the very
serious incredible allegations that were
raised against him would you and but
they weren't it I think you're right I'm
not sure that he was decisive in this
they weren't the only single minor to
determine parties though I would say in
this debate the Democrats were those
things too
and would you describe the allegation of
his client that she attended 10
consecutive gang rapes didn't report any
of this to police hotel any of her
friends or relatives and the judge
Cavanaugh was present at some of these
drugging the punch oh but wait she says
later he wasn't is that a credible
allegation do you think what strikes me
about about the allegation and and I
believe she swore under penalty of
perjury perjury excuse me in her
declaration so you know I think as a
lawyer that that says something to me
but it was striking to me that she
contradicted in a later interview yeah
so so my takeaway from that when senator
Collins said I think was October 2nd
Tucker that she won right that
allegation to be included in the scope
of the FBI investigation to me that
would have been the right way forward
allowing for the FBI to fairly impartial
II assess the credibility of her
allegations by building and how would
they go about doing that since since she
as you said most he gave her declaration
under oath she named no other person
present other than people who already
under oath denied that she was telling
the truth there was literally nobody to
interview except her and she was making
claims that were so stupid that even
Democratic senators were blush I mean
there weren't ten gang rapes in a row
and Chevy Chase and no one heard about
it I mean that's just not true and
everyone knew it so why wouldn't
democrats stay too creepy porn lawyer
come on now you know this is not helpful
i mean i think i think you did see some
members give far greater credence to dr.
Blasi Ford's testimony I mean if
anything the focus on dr. Ford's
testimony was was very powerful in part
because she did come forward and she did
testify and members had an opportunity
to ask her questions but you know look
that the broader take away from me here
is that unfortunately the FBI
investigation was not comprehensive in
fact judge justice Cavanaugh and dr.
Blaser Ford weren't even interviewed as
part of that investigation
so I think it was a missed opportunity
for us to clear what are you saying I
just wanted to understand okay
somebody's wonder say what you're saying
are you saying that because creepy porn
lawyers client the one who claimed the
ten consecutive public gang rapes that
didn't happen and you know what as well
as I the fact that she wasn't
interviewed by the FBI means that he
shouldn't have been confirmed is that
are you really saying that I just want
to make sure you're referring to mr.
avenatti when you're using that term I
don't want your shows I'm not I'm not
fully permitted right the the lawyer who
represented stormy Daniels who's now a
leading presidential candidate for the
Democratic Saviour of the Republic
meeting in the morning
let's get to let's get to that because
I'm not sure he's a leader well I mean
he's visiting he's been invited by
Democrats in Iowa and New Hampshire and
other early primary States but let me
just say are you saying that because his
client the ten gang rape in a row client
she wasn't interviewed about her
ludicrous claims that somehow Cavanaugh
shouldn't have been confirmed is that
what you're saying that's not what I
said I wish that she had been
interviewed and I wish that the FBI
could have probed her story and then
offered a more full more complete record
I that's what I'm saying I think that we
have a missed opportunity here because
there are very serious questions that
are still outstanding because the FBI
investigation was not allowed to be as
complete and holistic as is I think many
members certainly Democratic members of
the Senate Judiciary Committee you saw
their statement wish that it had been
and I suspect if you could just quickly
bottom-line it for me just about the
creepy porn lore the CPL component of
this would you say you're happy to have
him in your party and he should keep
doing what he's doing because that's
what Democrats stand for or maybe he
should go back to doing whatever it is
he does I mean we're a big tent party
I'm happy for anyone who's stepping
forward and standing up for what they
believe in but look it's gonna be a
really crowded primary field in 2020 so
I am NOT not foolish enough to offer any
kind of forecast who's going to be the
nominee in 2010 well I'm rooting for him
look I'm not even a Democrat but I'm
just I just want to tell you I'm for
squaring his I hear that